Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
doctor strange 2 video all about ghost rider there
was a new report that we might see him during
multiverse of madness so i'll explain what's going
on with that what that might look like and there's
even some new reports about the villain of doctor
strange 2 so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we'll actually be getting that
first doctor strange 2 trailer later this year
really excited to see what sam raimi did with his
take on the movie but recently if you didn't see
the news the hashtag show people are claiming
to have personally seen concept art from doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness showcasing a new
version of ghostwriter that they're claiming is
the johnny blaze version of the character there's
already a pretty deep connection between the ghost
rider character in the mcu and what they were
doing on Wandavision with the darkhold and what's
happening with that during doctor strange 2 so
i'll explain those connections in a second we
also already know the movie is going to be direct
crossover with spider-man 3 no way home not only
is it the next marvel movie right after spider-man
3 but doctor strange benedict cumberbatch himself
is a big character during spiderman no way
home and there were some easter eggs on the set
that seemingly referenced some of the things that
they were trying to set up back during Wandavision
that doesn't mean that scarlet witch is going to
show up during spider-man no way home they might
reference something in a post-credits scene if
we're talking about spider-man 3 teasing doctor
strange 2 stuff and characters i think it's mostly
just going to be through benedict cumberbatch's
character it's just that they're rolling so hard
on the multiverse trope and that's what they were
starting to set up at the end of Wandavision
in that post-credits scene but we do know that
scarlet witch's storyline will be one of the major
forces driving the plot in doctor strange 2 they
did a pretty good job of teasing what was going on
with that during the Wandavision post credit scene
vague as it may have been they did clarify a
few things since then wanda takes off at the end
of the finale and went into hiding according to
the showrunner and also elizabeth olsen tried to
explain that herself so that no one would be able
to find her and hold her accountable for what she
did in west view there was a big joke about that
like she just takes off without saying she's sorry
they said she did that so that they wouldn't
hold her to task and so people like dr strange
wouldn't stop her or try to take the darkhold from
her so metaphorically and literally wanda goes off
the map to learn everything that she can from
the darkhold which obviously is one of the most
dangerous books that she has agatha harkness
was trying to tell her that during the finale
like you're going to need me for what's coming
that's all about the prophecy that she's supposed
to bring about the end of the world that's
inside the darkhold so she not only wants to
learn about that prophecy she also wants to learn
more about the nature of chaos magic and then she
gets the big teaser that her children might be in
another dimension trapped somewhere so she's also
going to try and use the darkhold to find them so
in wanda messing with chaos magic the multiverse
the darkhold that sort of sets the stage for the
villain of doctor strange 2 to take advantage and
come into the main mcu dimension which is exactly
what doctor strange is trying to prevent that's
dr strange's whole job is protecting the main
mcu reality from threats from other dimensions
from other realities we also just learned about
that deleted doctor strange storyline and all
the deleted scenes that we're going to feature
benedict cumberbatch's character they said the
plan originally was to have dr strange's character
be the one to create all those fake commercials
during the episodes and he was supposed to have
been using them to try and communicate with wanda
inside the hex and get her to realize what was
happening and warn her about act of the harkness
so make all the jokes you want doctor
strange knew that it was agatha all along
then he would have appeared in the finale to teach
her about her chaos magic and then i believe the
post-credits scene would have still been the
same like her stealing the darkhold and taking
off before doctor strange could take it into safe
keeping so that she could read from it learn more
about her magic and then try to use it to find
a way to bring her children billy and tommy back
as you hear them crying out there there's also
the idea of wanda as a nexus being as they were
trying to tease in that last big commercial not
only is she a nexus being but there's also the
idea of the concept of the nexus of the multiverse
like the gateway to all realities all dimensions
but i think one of the reasons why we're
probably hearing about ghost writer references
possibly being in doctor strange 2 is
because kevin feige said a long time ago
that one of the things that excited him so much
about the doctor strange character was that he was
the gateway to the supernatural characters in the
mcu he said doing the supernatural stories through
the doctor strange movies is the major reason why
now they can do the blade movie and they have a
justification to logically explain how vampires
can exist in the mcu alongside captain america
and iron man the other characters there were a lot
of you asking why they didn't include the blade
movie in that last big marvel phase 4 trailer but
i think the idea is that just a little further off
in the development of that and it will come at
some point after the fantastic four movie like
late 2023 unless there's some big delay they run
into in the next year or so another great example
of a supernatural character that they're doing now
that we'll see next year is the mark spectre moon
knight character in that disney plus series he's
being played by oscar isaac i'm sure it's going
to be fantastic series and if we're talking about
blade the darker characters dracula obviously big
vampire character that everybody knows about
is a big moon knight crossover villain there's
no hard release date for the moon night series
right now i think it's supposed to drop sometime
next spring i'll do more videos about that when
they release more information you probably saw the
behind the scenes video that oscar isaac posted
of him training for his fight scenes he will be
hardcore during that series but is bringing
it back around to the ghost rider character
he's a character you could totally use in darker
disney plus series or future supernatural movies
like the blade sequels in fact talking more about
the Wandavision and doctor strange two connections
if you watched agents of shield the ghostwriter
character the spirit of vengeance already has a
deep connection to the things that are going on in
those stories through the darkhold itself they did
a version of the darkhold during agents of shield
season 4 as part of their ghost rider storyline
now the ghost writer that they did was mostly
the robbie reyes version but they did a bunch
of different iterations of the character so they
teased the johnny blaze version and the dandy
catch versions but coulson also got to have the
spirit of vengeance like coulson ghostrider mack
also got to have the spirit of vengeance so he was
another version of ghost rider during the series
you get to be ghostwriter you get to be
ghostwriter everybody in the audience gets
to be ghost rider the version of the darkhold that
they did on agents of shield looked a little bit
different like they gave it a big time upgrade for
Wandavision just to make it look more like one of
the books of magic that you would see inside
the doctor strange movies but in the comics
the darkhold was written by c'thon he's the god
of chaos the most powerful of the elder gods and
he's also the source of all chaos magics that's
why wanda has chaos magic is because he made it
that way it seemed that they were trying to tease
him through the darkhold in the Wandavision finale
implying that maybe he was trying to manipulate
wanda using her children in that post-credit
scene like he might be trying to trick wanda into
bringing him to the main mcu dimension but you all
remember the mephisto jokes the funnier connection
here just because of all the mephisto jokes that
were going around during Wandavision is that
mephisto the character was actually the person in
the comics who bonded the spirit of vengeance to
johnny blaze in the first place that doesn't mean
that mephisto is gonna suddenly show up when ghost
rider shows up in the mcu eventually they change
the comic book stories all the time and there are
weird considerations about what they can and can't
do inside china i know there's always a question
about that but with all the stuff happening in the
mcu connecting all these dots it's just a funny
coincidence i've also heard a rumor recently about
shuma gorath possibly being the villain of doctor
strange 2 he's been a long time big doctor strange
villain in the comics if you're not familiar with
the character he's like an extra dimensional being
who's a boss level upgrade from dormammu like we
talk about the nightmare character we talk about
mephisto we talk about dormammu shuma gorath
is kind of like their boss he's another one
of the eldritch lores sort of exists in his own
dimension he talks about being from outside of all
existence from the void of nothingness outside
existence but one of the names that shuma gorath
goes by in the comics is also lord of chaos so
because conceptually he's a much easier villain to
swallow than say like c'thon also much easier to
pronounce his name than pronouncing C'thon's name
what marvel might wind up doing just to simplify
things to the cliffs notes version is changing the
backstory of the darkhold in the mcu to make
it so that schumacheth is the one who wrote
it and have him be the source of wanda's chaos
magic if they're calling him the lord of chaos
and i believe early on scott derrickson even said
that he thought about using schumachorth as the
villain of the first doctor strange movie before
they settled on dormammu it's just that shuma
gorath is so powerful that you think that they
would save him for like the last doctor strange
movie if they're going to do a trilogy of movies
eventually but if we're talking about escalating
things in marvel phase 4 and if doctor strange 2
is meant to be one of the biggest marvel phase 4
movies he would definitely be a threat that's just
as big if not bigger than thanos theoretically
cannot wait to hear spider-man wisecracking about
a giant octopus-looking creature floating in the
sky with a huge eyeball so just don't be surprised
if they do wind up combining the C'thon in the
schumacherth characters in the mcu as for who they
would get to play their new version of ghost rider
in the mcu new version of johnny blaze i know a
lot of people would love to see keanu reeves be
their new version of johnny blaze right around the
time the avengers end game was coming out kevin
feige did admit that they were meeting with him
about a project in the mcu but he also said that
they met with keanu reeves during every big marvel
phase just about new projects that he might be a
fit for and which characters he was interested in
and the reason why you haven't seen him in the mcu
yet playing a character is because they haven't
found the right character for him yet that he
connects with on a fundamental level but everyone
let me know in the comments who do you want to be
the new version of johnny blaise rider when he
eventually does show up in a new marvel project
they did have a ghost rider tv show they were
going to do with the robbie reyes version from
agents of shield was going to be like a spin-off
with his version of the character but when kevin
feige took over all the marvel television shows
they basically canceled that ghost rider tv
show and now the way gabrielle luna talks about
it the actor he says he doesn't expect to ever
come back as that character so it does sound like
when they introduce a new ghostwriter it'll be a
completely new version of the character with a
totally different actor but if we hear any more
news about what's going on with that or any new
doctor strange 2 news of course i'll do a video
about it but while you wait for everything click
here for my big marvel phase 4 trailer video in
my eternals trailer and you can click here for my
brand new venom let there be carnage trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!